severodonezk y el nombre de la ciudad
está inscrito con los colores nacionales
de ucrania
una ciudad industrial antes de la guerra
ahora es una ciudad fantasma casi el 95%
de los residentes han huido los
edificios dañados y bombardeados son una
vista frecuente solo quedan los que no
pueden irse a
donde quieres que vayamos a donde
con qué dinero nos vamos a ir
no tenemos ni un céntimo y no tenemos
adónde ir
frente a este gran edificio hay un grupo
de voluntarios están ayudando a
transportar los suministros necesarios
leche en polvo carne enlatada patatas
fritas detrás del ayuntamiento otro
equipo de voluntarios misa y alexei
también están haciendo entregas es
difícil recorrer varios kilómetros
conducen por la acera durante un rato
antes de tener que bajarse y quitar las
ramas de los árboles
los voluntarios llegan finalmente a un
complejo de edificios de apartamentos
uno tras otro los residentes salen de
sus sótanos es la primera vez que
reciben suministros en más de 50 días
para estos vecinos es una oportunidad de
verse y ponerse al día
pero la guerra no está lejos es hora de
volver rápidamente a sus refugios del
sótano esta mujer dice que las bombas
nunca paran
no tengo miedo de los rusos ni de los
ucranianos solo sé que todos los bandos
están siendo bombardeados de igualdad el
exterior es primavera en la región lo
que significa temporada de tulipanes
frente a esta cocina improvisada una
mujer con una escoba dice que está
barriendo la guerra